my name is alex i'm gerry barky our
product is super multiplexing star
airframe we incorporated all our own
components met capable caring a wireless
video camera for a live view from the
ground you also made that so we can swap
it out for digital still camera light
point and shoot models 7.1 megapixels as
a view out the belly this is live camera
you fly by the video on a visual contact
a radio range is about a mile and a half
hour video contact is about three miles
so we're limited by a radio range you
can fly out a visual contact use those
video goggles it's also on a movable
mouth go left and right
we the digital camera and the video
camera there's so many different
applications and firefighting to
wildlife research to the military we
found that our plane is incredibly
cost-effective to compared to any
commercially available plane
the military